we need to go all in from a hardware
perspective they need to see that we are
willing to stand up and allow an ally to
have what they need to have to
aggressively prosecute their own defense
and by the way I believe if we had done
that early on in Russia we wouldn't be
in this circumstance with Ukraine and we
should take that as a lesson for China
and Taiwan and other areas in
Asia
[Music]
hello everyone watching and
listening today I'm pleased to speak
with lawyer Federal prosecutor and
former New Jersey governor now running
for president Chris Christie we
discussed the unfortunate and
disproportional power of teachers unions
the potentially Perpetual state of the
Ukraine Russia War the impact of the
Biden laptop Scandal and why Donald
Trump at least in Mr Christie's opinion
might not be the right Republican
candidate going
forward all right well thank you for
agreeing to talk to me today and and to
everyone who's listening and watching um
it's quite an exciting development as
far as I'm concerned to see these long
form dialogues take their place in the
in political discourse because it really
allows people the opportunity to unfold
their Vision so I I thought the first
thing I might ask you cuz I think this
is the question that's foremost on my
mind and should be on the minds of
people who are watching and listening is
why do you think that you would be a
good president what what is it that
makes you stand out from the other the
rest of the pack say on the Republican
side or on the Democrat side as well why
should people be concentrating on your
campaign well facts first off thanks for
having me on and uh I look forward to
this kind of long form conversation as
well I think it's much more informative
for folks I I'd say three things come to
mind immediately um the first is that
you know I think we've gotten in in our
country too small in terms of our
politics um we're arguing about what I
think are relatively small things in the
grand scheme of what our country should
be working on we're dividing each other
into smaller and smaller groups we're uh
pitting each other against each other um
and anger seems to be the predominant
emotion um I I want to be president
because I want to do the big things um
this country I think has always been at
its greatest when it does big things and
you know for me um some of those
examples of some of those things are our
educational system um K to 12 I think is
failing our country and our families
miserably when a third of our kids can't
read at grade level in this country we
need to have a radical change in the way
we educate kids K to 12 and I'm going to
go into some more detail on that
hopefully later in the conversation but
I want to put parents much more in
charge of those things uh and Empower
them to do it um second crime in this
country has become um a a near epidemic
problem in our cities uh and it's
affecting quality of life and the
ability of people to enjoy all the great
things that we have in America's cities
and and this is because prosecutors
locally have decided they don't want to
prosecute uh quality of life crime and
violent crime in the way that they used
to I think if you don't have a sense of
the rule of law and Law and Order in
your country um that that diminishes
everyone's ability to enjoy their lives
and to make the most of them and so as
president and I would make sure um that
we send Federal prosecutors into all the
cities that have significant crime
problems if the local prosecutors won't
prosecute that that violent crime we
will and make sure that we clean up
what's going on in our cities uh third I
think that America's got to continue to
play a leading role in the world and I
think we have too much dissent in our
own party which is fine to have the
argument but I think the argument needs
to be resolved on behalf of America
being a leader around the world and so
that's why I favor our support in
Ukraine and would enhance it increase it
because I think it's a proxy war right
now between the United States in the
west and China China supplying the the
money for Russia to prosecute this War
uh and the expansionism that has always
been a part of Russian foreign policy is
right on display and we need to stop it
right where it is because a free and
secure Europe is very important to
America's political and economic future
uh and and lastly what I'd say is that
we don't talk to each other anymore in
government uh we we tweet at each other
or or whatever it's called now EX at
each other um we we use social media to
do that stuff the the reason I'm
Different is because I was a republican
governor for eight years in a democratic
state with a democratic State
Legislature and I had to figure out how
to work with the other side to
accomplish things that mattered and that
were consistent with my principles
there's nobody else in the race that's
had that experience and that's most what
it's like in Washington DC and we need a
president again who's willing to spend
his or her political capital on building
those relationships and trying to get
things done I've always operated Jordan
in my career in politics on the
principle that it's harder to hate up
close and the the more that we get to
know each other um the more we get to
know each other's families what
motivated us to get into public life
what our priorities are what we really
want to accomplish um the greater chance
we have to be able to get things done
for the American people um and so so I
think that makes me a lot different than
any other candidate in this race and it
will allow me to solve problems like
immigration solve problems like our
entitlement programs and their impending
um bankruptcy and the effect that would
have on the American people so that's
why people should be focusing on me and
on my on my
campaign okay so you outlined four basic
categories
education uh Law and Order let's say
foreign policy America's role in the
world and then dialogue between
Republicans and Democrats let's let's
start at the top of that list on the
education side I know that as Governor
you um introduced a number of
educational reforms I was reading today
that at at least at the moment there's
no long-term indication that they've
actually improved educational
performance that's not surprising to me
because it actually turns out to be
quite difficult to to reform education
in a way that actually makes a
difference and and maybe that's wrong I
haven't done a lot
of um delving into the direct
consequences of your reforms but I do
have some specific questions on the
education front so and here's one that's
really perplexed me for a long period of
time
so I worked at Harvard in 92 to '98 and
I spent a lot of time
analyzing research that was done in the
Departments or in the faculties of
education and the faculties of Education
since the early 60s have abdicated their
responsibility entirely they generally
they generally train the least motivated
students at University often the ones
with the worst grades de devolve into
teaching because they can't figure out
what else to do the quality of research
that the faculties of Education have
produced to call it appalling is barely
to scraped the surface they've
championed whole word reading they've
championed self-esteem training uh
emotional social learning multiple
intelligences like a whole emotional
intelligence a whole panoply of of con
Concepts that have no scientific
standing whatsoever and have done
nothing but hurt kids and they've become
they're likely among the most woke
disciplines the farthest left
disciplines that have emerged within the
university yet they have a hammer lock
on teacher certification and that gives
them access to 50% of American state
budget so one of the things I'm curious
about I also noticed that you ched the
Republican Governors Association I
cannot understand why the Republican
Governors haven't taken teacher
certification away from the faculties of
Education I mean why are they allowed to
have a hammerlock on teacher production
there's no evidence whatsoever that
they're good at doing their jobs and
plenty of evidence to the contrary so
well that's a specific question I have
but I'm also curious about what else
you're um devoted to on the educational
reform front and why you think it would
what why you think it would work well
let me start by talking about your
specific thing it was one of the big
fights that I had in New Jersey that I
wound up not being able to win because I
needed legislative support to get it
done and as hard as I tried to do it um
the teachers unions as you know are an
enormous political force and while I
diminished a lot of their influence I
couldn't get um off of the teacher
certification front and I think you put
your finger on something that is
extraordinarily important if you're
going to reform our national education
system is the idea that great teachers
do not often come from Departments of
Education um in our universities and
colleges and so that's one of the one of
the fronts that we have to have a
national conversation and arguments
about um more broadly I do think that um
when you talk about the hammerlock on
50% of State budgets you're right and in
some instances is even more uh in terms
of the amount of money that's spent
we're spending about $800 billion
Nationwide a year on K to2 education and
I think it's time to have the federal
government lead the way and encourage
states that are already providing
educational choice and those that are
not um to move much towards much more
towards a choice model and not just for
underprivileged uh folks but for
everybody
and that if Public Schools will only get
better if they have to
compete and if they have to compete in a
meaningful way against other options
private schools parochial schools but
also within the public system a broader
availability of charter schools and
Renaissance schools which operate much
differently so when you look back in in
New Jersey one of the places where we
had we our reforms did have a huge
impact was in the city of Camden um
where they they had six of the 10 lowest
performing schools individual schools in
the entire State and what we did was
take over the Board of Education there
and we encouraged the development of
Charter and Renaissance schools in the
city and authorized them um to compete
with the traditional public schools and
what you've seen Jordan is an enormous
increase in both the reading and math
scores if you look at the last 10 years
in the city of Camden there's been
enormous increase in that um in the in
the K to5 range um and I think that that
competition is leads to other reforms
that are really necessary for instance
um you know having a longer school year
having a 10 and a half to an 11 month
school year rather than the school year
we do now um having longer school days
you know kids need more time both every
day and throughout the year um to be
educated in the right way and especially
kids who come from our inner cities and
may not necessarily have the supported
home to encourage the type of learning
that becomes holistic um and so we need
to reform this in every way we can and
provide more choice and give parents the
financial resources they need to be able
to effectuate that choice so if you want
to go to a public school if you have a
good Public School in your in your town
continue to go to it and your money will
go to public school but if you choose to
send them to a charter school
Renaissance school private school pral
school um you should have the resources
in an account to be able to spend on
your child's education rather than
continuing to cow toow to the public
sector teachers unions um that as we saw
most starkly during coid care only about
protecting the least of their members
and not in the main in educating our
children so so I would like to delve a
bit more into you said that when you
tried
to transform the hammerlock of the uh
teachers union say on te on on on the
provision of teaching in New Jersey that
you you battle to a standstill and that
was partly because you were also facing
a Democrat controlled legislative
assembly and so of course that makes it
more difficult but I'm I'm I'm still I'm
I'm my curiosity in this front isn't
satiated yet because it looks to me like
such a colossal failure on the
Republican side both at the state level
local state and National level to allow
you know we're in the midst of a
terrible culture War it's not exactly
obvious that the even the classic
liberals or the conservatives are
winning it's clearly the case that the
radicals have got a hold of the
education system they're doing that
through the faculties of Education I
can't understand how it can be that the
Republicans have essentially been blind
to this for 60 years it's 60 years now
given that the long-term future of the
political State rests upon the
information that kids are receiving in
schools with regards to their political
education but now you but you have
hands-on experience with this you tried
to fight the fight and it was very very
difficult for you to bring about any
reform so so two questions there why
exactly was it so difficult what is it
that the teachers unions manage with
their access to these great uh walloping
chunks of financial resource and also
why do you think why are you convinced
that the provision of choice among
parents is the proper primary target in
relationship to educational
reform first on on the the battle on
certification I agree with you by the
way in in states where um Republicans
control everything
it's it's astonishing to me that you
wouldn't focus on teacher certification
and taking that out of the hands of the
professional teachers unions um and and
so to me it was one of the things that
we focused on very early on so it wasn't
something we missed it it it gets to
your second point which is I give you
for instance in in um in my state we
have 200,000 members of the teachers
union in our state
that create through their dues which at
the time I was governor were $700 a year
so the teachers union was collecting
$140 million a year and they didn't pay
a nickel chore teacher salaries teacher
pension or teacher healthare and that
money was just a slush fund to reward
their friends and to punish their
enemies that's a lot of money Jordan in
a state and when and and the best
indication of it is if you look at the
state capital capital in Trenton New
Jersey um when when I would look out the
front door of the state house beside the
State House the second largest building
on State Street in Trenton was the
teachers union
building um it it was no mistake they
wanted to send that message every time a
legislator walked in and out of that
building that they're bigger and
stronger than any other interest group
in the state now look I campaigned
against them and won twice Statewide um
it's possible to win these things but in
a state legislature dominated by
democrats they essentially buy them
Jordan I mean they just buy them both in
terms of buying them with favor but also
buying them through fear and
intimidation and you know they went
after the Senate a Democratic Senate
President in my state because he went
with me on some educational reform
issues um most particularly pension
reform uh for teachers and health
benefit reform for teachers so they'd
have to pay more into those systems to
make them more solvent um they went
after him three different elections and
the guy is the president of the Iron
Workers Union in New Jersey a fellow
Union member they went after him three
times the third time they finally
defeated him and he's out of the
legislature now so they try to show
persistence with their object lessons
and in a state where you have a
democratic legislature or a Democratic
governor you just saw this in
Pennsylvania Josh Piro ran as a Centrist
Democrat for governor promising that he
would provide educational Choice the
Republican legislature put the bill on
his desk and he vetoed it under pressure
from the teachers union and broke his
word that he gave during the campaign
and during the transition and so it's
another example of it lastly you asked
why I focus on Parental choice because I
think it's one of the hardest arguments
to argue against that if in fact your
education that you're providing in the
traditional Public Schools is so great
that of course parents would choose it
but if they if it isn't parents should
have the right to make that choice for
their kids and and it should be any
parent gets the right to make gets the
right to make that choice I do think
Jordan that our our history has shown
that competition does almost always
bring
Improvement and also exposes
weakness and that could be another way
to get at the teach your certification
issue when because remember these
Charter Schools private schools
parochial schools often can operate
under different rules um they don't have
unions in the main that they have to
deal with and can hire some different
folks and I think that that can help by
showing how successful they are to break
the the hammerlock that you very rightly
pointed out at the top of this
conversation on teacher certification in
our Public Schools right so it allows
for more experimentation with regards to
the provision of Education corre
highlights weaknesses and and allows for
for the poorer players to to be to be
deselected by the market right so the
experimentation issue there seems key as
well it doesn't hurt as well I suppose
to also devolve back to parents the
responsibility to pay some attention to
exactly how their children are being
educated what do you think strategically
what do you think strategically might be
done apart from focusing on Parental
choice amongst the Republicans or more
classically liberal or conservatively
oriented people to push back against the
the the the the Monopoly that's enjoyed
by the teachers unions and the teacher
certification process what did you learn
what did you learn strategically from
the battle you engaged in in New Jersey
well with the successes that we had
Jordan the way we got them was by
pointing out common sensical problems
with the way the system operates so for
instance I did over a 100 Town Hall
meetings on this issue across our state
um on the issues of of pension and
health benefits When I became Governor
uh a typical teacher who would retire at
25 years of service with a a large
pension 70% of salary of their highest
salary they would have paid they would
have used all the money they paid into
the system after two and a half years of
retirement um and teachers never paid a
nickel towards their health benefits in
our state while they were working and in
retirement the taxpayers paid all of it
so I used to go to town hall meetings
and say how many of you would like that
deal how many of you have that deal and
nobody would raise their hand and I said
well you're paying for that when people
came to recognize that they were paying
for that type of extravagant retirement
and health benefit system the teachers
union approval in our state because we
pulled it went from when I started these
meetings in the mid 70s down to the
mid-30s and people saw the Union as
selfish and self-consumed and abusive of
the taxpayers what that did Jordan was
it opened up the conversation on
everything else because once you show
that the representatives of these
teachers were selfish and self-consumed
and not focused on quality
um that was problem one problem two was
I went um in order to try to break this
Monopoly I went to some of the worst
school districts in our state and
pointed out two significant facts beside
the underperformance of the students the
first was that um they turned out to be
the most expensive school districts so
for instance in Asbury Park New Jersey
we were paying
$444,000 a
pupil to get awful performance in in the
city of Newark we had $36,000 per pupil
for awful performance in the city of
Campton $38,000 per pupil they could
have gone to any private school in
America at that time at for that number
or less and gotten a significantly
better
education um secondly we then talked
about the way the teachers union
protects the worst of their members so
for instance in Newark we had over a
hundred teachers who literally reported
every day to what they called the rubber
room where they were not permitted to
teach anymore but the teachers union
prevented them from being fired so the
school district made the decision Jordan
if you can believe it that it would be
better off for the kids to pay these
teachers to do nothing than to have them
in a classroom yeah yeah yeah when you
pointed these things out to folks it
opened up the entire conversation so for
instance I was able to negotiate with
Randy wearden believe it or not Merit
pay for teachers in Newark that for the
first time we would actually reward the
teachers who were showing greater
results with greater pay and take away
this kind of monopolistic view that
every teacher is the same and every
teacher should be paid the same based
purely upon experience rather than on
performance that would have never
happened Jordan if I hadn't brought
their poll numbers down to the mid-30s
and they were really worried that the
legislature that they had bought might
be willing to sell them down the River
so you know these are the things that we
need to do on a national level and by
the way the good thing about Republican
governors in some of these states has
been that they have expanded Choice
significantly they need to take the next
steps and with a federal government that
could condition uh Educational Funding
on taking those new steps which is what
I would do as president you could
encourage even more people I think to be
able to do some of these reforms that
have shown to be
effective all right so
well let's turn let's turn to I guess
what strikes me as the second
most crucial element on your list of of
policy folky and that would be foreign
policy especially in relationship to
what's happening in in Ukraine and with
Russia and so that's obviously a
terrible conundrum and a terribly
dangerous situation and so the first
question I guess I would have for you on
with regard to that issue
is how do you think we got ourselves
into this mess I mean we had a chance in
the 1990s I believe to have pulled
Russia firmly into the sphere of the
West and we seem to have bungled out
somewhat irredeemably and now we have
this terrible war in Ukraine that seems
to be settling down for the Long Hall as
far as I can tell with the additional
danger of emboldening China and so and I
don't see I haven't heard from anybody
I've interviewed or really anybody I've
talked to anything that constitutes a
reasonable vision for for victory or
peace so two questions you know how in
the world did we manage to get into
something this idiotic and number two
given that we are here and we could have
the best possible of all outcomes
whatever that would be what would those
outcomes look like and how how would you
work towards them okay so how did we get
here I believe it was a series of
mistakes and Mis evaluations starting
with the the um the Clinton
Administration um and every president
since then has been guilty of this so um
I think Bill Clinton did not focus as he
should have I mean George Bush 41 gave
him the opportunity you just spoke about
um by the Berlin Wall coming down
because of the efforts I believe of
Reagan and Bush 41 um the ending of the
Soviet Union and the setting up of at
least what was a nominally democratic Uh
Russian Federation under Boris yelson um
to try to
bring them into the league of of of uh
fair and and just Nations um I don't
think Bill Clinton nearly spent the time
focused on that that he should have and
because of that because of his
distracted focus on foreign policy and
other places um I think he missed an
opportunity um with Russia then I think
Bush 43 misevaluated Vladimir Putin I
think you might remember him saying you
know I looked into his eyes and saw his
soul well he obviously didn't or the
solely thought he saw wasn't there
Vladimir Putin from the beginning in my
view was a a a former KGB operative who
was a zaris Soviet type of leader who
was intent on and he said that the
breakup of the Soviet Union was the
greatest tragedy historic tragedy of his
lifetime so how do you expect Jordan
that you're going to willingly have a
guy like that give up his
expansionist um
aspirations and so under George W bush
he was allowed to go back into Geor
Georgia no
ramifications under Barack Obama he was
allowed to seize
Crimea and other parts of Ukraine no
ramifications under Donald Trump uh he
continued to mass troops on the border
of Ukraine and Donald Trump did not
supply as Barack Obama did not Ukraine
with the type of weapons that could
deter uh Russia from wanting to invade
and ultimately Joe Biden given how badly
he botched the withdrawal from
Afghanistan sent a signal to Putin that
that he was not up to fighting this
fight and Putin made his move to do what
he'd always wanted to do was bring
Ukraine back into the Russian Federation
and so the way we got into this mess was
a series of uh
inattentiveness
misevaluation and weakness that was read
by Putin as
permission because when we didn't fight
him on Georgia and we didn't fight him
on
Crimea you could say it's reasonable for
to conclude that we might not fight him
on taking all of
Ukraine we hadn't made Ukraine a part of
NATO so he had every reason to believe
that we wouldn't fight back on this
that's how I think we wound up here I
think because of the Chinese involvement
in this remember before Putin went to
war before he made the decision to go to
war president G came to
Moscow met with Putin and said publicly
there are no limits to the French
friendship between China and Russia well
Putin took that to mean exactly what it
meant which was that China would
financially support Russia to go in and
take Ukraine and so we are now seeing a
proxy war the the appropriate conclusion
of the war is to have Ukraine have the
ability to drive Russia out of in my
view the newest parts of what they've
taken of Ukraine
and then to
negotiate the borders and to thereafter
once the war is ended to admit Ukraine
to Nato so that Russia would now know
that there was a price to pay for their
Invasion and their barbarism of their
Invasion um and that price is that now
Finland is a member of NATO on their
border you've got and if you add Ukraine
um this is a much worse result than
Russia could have ever have expected on
their border but they brought it on
themselves and I will tell you also that
having just gotten back from Ukraine 10
days ago I could tell you that um the
barbarism that's gone on there by the
Russian army is
unspeakable the murder of civilians and
burying them in Shallow Graves the
gouging out of eyes while people are
alive cutting off of ears and in my view
Jordan worse than anything thing 20,000
children Ukrainian children have been
kidnapped by the Russian army and and
sent to Russia to be reprogrammed to
work against Ukraine I met some of these
mothers who have had their children
taken away from them they don't know
whether their children are dead or alive
whether they're being cared for or
abused and whether they'll ever see them
again these are the type of things that
America cannot permit an authoritarian
regime to do to a free
country and to do so with impunity and
we need to send a message the West as a
whole needs to send a message with
American leadership that that's not
permissible because if we don't Putin
will not stop there remember the
Russians have always wanted to have
Poland because Poland was the way that
they were invaded in both world wars and
they have wanted that level of buffer uh
and I so I don't believe if we permit
this that he'll stop at Ukraine that
he'll continue to try to assemble as
best he can the old Soviet
Union so the concerns for me in that
regard
are twofold and you outlined a bit of
what might constitute a vision for
victory first issue is after World War I
Germany was severely punished for its
expansionist proclivities and that
resulted in the Treaty of Versailles and
that was designed to permanently weaken
Germany and that turned out to be that
vindictive treaty turned out to be a
very very very bad idea so attempting to
permanently weaken a powerful industrial
economy we have some historical
precedent for assuming that that might
breed exactly the opposite result so
I've talked to Hawks on the American
side who think that the investment of
tens of billions of dollars so far into
Ukraine if the consequence of that was
the weakening of Russia's military might
then that was a small price to pay but
the Treaty of Versailles issue lurks in
my mind as a counter
example now we might hope for regime
change in the in in Russia as a
consequence of the difficulties of this
war but again if you look at Russia
historically it's by no means obvious
that Putin is the worst leader that the
that Russia has ever had and plus it's
also
strikes me as risky to destabilize the
conventional forces of an extremely
powerfully armed nuclear enemy given
that once
the normal courses of warfare are
exhausted the conventional forces the
nuclear option is the only one left and
so it seems to me that we may be
tempting Russia in that direction and
then finally it's not obvious to me at
all that the Russians will give up these
newer territories you're speaking of the
Dawn bass I believe and the and the
territories on the Eastern side now I
don't know ever when I'm reading
reliable information from that area of
the world but my understanding is there
is some degree of support among the
local population especially the Russian
speakers for the Russian what incursion
into those territories and so and I'm
not trying to justify that that's that's
not my point I'm trying to lay out the
complexities my sense is that Russia
regards these as rightful territories of
of their of their state and that they'll
be very very loath to give up any
territory it's hard for me to imagine
that Putin could do that as well without
having to declare something like defeat
which is very unlikely it's very
unlikely thing for him to do given all
the options he has in front of him
so why do you think it's realistic to
assume that with sufficient pressure the
Russians will give up those Eastern
territories dabass and to what degree
are you concerned that pushing in that
direction will tilt the Russians towards
well one option is obviously the use of
tactical nuclear weapons on the
battlefield and so I see way more ways
of this getting out of hand than I see
ways of it proceeding towards something
approximating a reasonable conclusion so
well I'll leave you with that mess of
questions to to jle as you say a lot to
unpack there so let me start I believe
where you started which is I am not
advocating for a Treaty of Versailles
with Russia and I'm not advocating for
intentional
destabilization um of of Russia or
demilitarization which is an absolutely
unrealistic goal which is what happened
to the Germans in the near- term after
the Treaty of Versailles so I'm not
advocating for that at all and I do
think that there are real concerns about
advocating for regime change because in
Russia the devil you know may be better
than the devil you don't um and and that
and we've seen that through history so
I'm not advocating for either one of
those
things um and I want to be clear that
I'm not saying that Victory would look
like regime change in Russia um I am
concerned about them as a nuclear power
being destabilized uh uh and so I'm not
advocating for those things what I am
saying though is that we have not yet
tested fully how much military pressure
can be put on Putin to get him to
concede some of those areas on the
Eastern side in the donbas um we have
not armed them enough let me give you an
example when I was in in in Ukraine 10
days ago president sesy told me that on
the average day in
August um Russia is is shooting 56,000
artillery shells into Ukraine Ukraine is
responding with
6,000 now almost an 11 to1 problem is
not giving Ukraine what they need to be
able to prosecute the war in the most
effective way they can and so I think
Joe Biden has given them enough just
enough not to lose L but not enough to
win and so part of what I think we need
to do here is to give the ukrainians the
ability to prosecute the war in the way
they see
fit and then see how Russia reacts it
may be once we've armed Ukraine
sufficiently for them to meet all of
their strategic goals
militarily that Russia still will not
concede some of those areas is well then
that's when you sit down and have a
conversation with your ally about what's
the best deal we can make here to bring
this to a conclusion but you can't
convince them the ukrainians it's in
their interest to do that when you
haven't given them the ability as they
see it and I think just given the
numbers they're right to be able to
prosecute the war in as aggressive a way
as it's being prosecuted against them
and so if we're in
we need to go all in from a hardware
perspective the other reason to do that
of course Jordan is the message it sends
to China Visa Taiwan and other areas in
Asia that they need to see that we are
willing to stand up and allow an ally to
have what they need to have to
aggressively prosecute their own
defense and China's watching very
closely on this front and we need to
send that message both as a country and
as an alliance very clearly to them and
by the way I believe if we had done that
early on in Russia we wouldn't be in
this circumstance with
Ukraine and we should take that as a
lesson for China and Taiwan and other
areas in Asia so I think I think that
tries to answer specifically um a number
of the things that you laid out in in
your
questions
are you looking for an all-in-one
e-commerce platform that can help you
easily set up and grow your business
online look no further than Shopify with
Shopify you can quickly and easily build
your own online store manage your
inventory and accept payments from
customers plus Shopify offers a range of
customizable themes and templates to
choose from so you can create a
professionall looking store without any
design experience it even helps
integrate with other popular tools to
help you sell across social media
marketplaces like Tik Tok Facebook
Facebook and Instagram with shopify's
24/7 support and an extensive Business
course Library that's available to
support you every step of the way
Shopify is thec Commerce platform
revolutionizing millions of businesses
worldwide if you're ready to get serious
about selling try Shopify today sign up
for a $1 per month trial period at
shopify.com
jbp go to shopify.com sjbp to take your
business to the next level today that's
shopify.com JB
BP okay so I'm going to ask one more
question with regard to foreign policy
especially pertaining to Ukraine
so the cynical part of me
thinks in relation to the dangers of the
military industrial complex that
Eisenhower warned us about back in the
1960s that the
war of attrition the endless war of
attrition in Afghanistan came to a halt
under Biden
and that put the military contractor
types in a difficult position because
the endless market for their Wares had
now dried up well now we've got a
situation where we have a war in Ukraine
that's settling down to be a very very
long and drawn out battle and you said
yourself that Biden has sent just enough
enough to the ukrainians not to lose but
not enough to win that certainly makes
the uh possibility of a long drawn out
and Hyper expensive War uh Paramount so
one of the things I'm wondering about is
do you think that the president with his
relatively short-term in power and the
multitude of his potential
responsibilities and division of
attention as was the case with Clinton
do you actually think that the president
can step into a situation like this a
new president with enough power and
credibility to stand up against the
continually active implicit forces
agitating for expensive
War yeah I think you not only can you
but you must now look the part of the
reason this is going to be a a longer
war is because because Obama Trump and
Biden have all failed to arm the
ukrainians quickly I mean think about
this Jordan they're now talking about
F-16 training and saying it's going to
take until next summer to train
Ukrainian Pilots to fly
F-16 this is absurd and it's the result
of wanting to drag it out so I think
your
suspicions in that regard could be
alleviated if we had acted more quickly
and I still think we can act quickly now
the Russians are still on their heels
here you have to believe that Putin
believed that he he'd be flying the
Russian flag uh over keev by this point
he's not anywhere close to that and so
we still have an opportunity by
aggressively arming them to shorten this
conflict if we continue to do what we're
doing you know what pasted is prologue
and if we continue to act the way we're
acting now and the war is not coming to
an end but is at a stalemate well then
you either have to you know act
differently or you're going to continue
to have stalemate so you either have to
withdraw
completely and allow the Russians to
completely take over Ukraine which is
unacceptable to me or you have to ramp
up the hardware you give so that you can
try to bring it to a to a speedier
conclusion now if you try that and it
doesn't work then negotiation is going
to be our only way of ending this and
we'll have a significant say in that
matter given that we have treated our
allies fairly and appropriately in
giving them a chance to win the war and
saying to them we gave you a chance with
you know much of what you've asked for
and you haven't been able to get it done
so we need to now step in and help to
negotiate a conclusion to this but until
we do that we are
absolutely consigning ourselves to a
stalemated situation here so that's why
I would be more
aggressive if you acquired the
presidency what priority would
addressing this conflict become and then
also given your strategy of sending
additional military aid to Ukraine how
do you protect yourself and your country
against the possibility of getting their
sleeve caught in the terrible machine
and being dragged in you know
completely because there's obviously
well you can see the complexity there so
you know how much of this how much would
this be a priority for your
Administration and and what do you do to
stop the US and the West as a whole the
rest of the world from getting dragged
into what could be a catastrophic
conflict let me go in reverse on your
questions the first is my view the way
to avoid getting Dragged In is twofold
one to make very
clear that there is not a circumstance
under which I would send American
soldiers or NATO soldiers to Ukraine but
secondly to arm them sufficiently so
that it would not be
necessary it is in action it is
timidity that gets that sleeve caught
into the machine of war and gets you
Dragged In
not the aggression of saying we're going
to give you
Ukraine every every resource you need
from a hardware perspective to prosecute
the war you think can be
winnable short
of
forces now on the flip side of that you
know as in terms of
priorities it would be a top three
priority from a foreign policy
perspective you know the first priority
is our relationship with China now
obviously that's interwoven with Ukraine
but we have many other issues that we
need to deal with with China in terms of
intellectual property in terms of um our
relationship with Taiwan in terms of um
our our need uh to make sure that the
Chinese are not sewing discontent around
the world climate issues with China
there's a lot of issues that we have
with China that we have to deal with
that would be a top three priority
secondly I would also be looking to
shore up our other alliances around the
world as one of the parts of dealing
with our Chinese relationship we should
have a better relationship with India
and we should be working on that we
should make sure inside our own
hemisphere that we are dealing with some
of the challenges that go on that don't
only affect us internationally but
domestically we live in the best
neighborhood in the world Jordan with
Mexico and Canada on our borders but we
need to strengthen that both
economically and
geopolitically to make sure that we deal
with some of the issues that we have
inside our own hemisphere so it would be
a top three priority along with
strengthening alliances and dealing very
directly with China on the issues that
are very very important to us um and to
the Chinese going forward um you know
they're the second largest economy in
the world we're we've become very
interwoven and we need to acknowledge
that fact and work in our own national
interests to make sure that the terms of
that relationship are ones that um give
us the opportunity uh to be as
successful as we can be so let's turn we
we are somewhat tight for time here so
let's turn our attention I'd like to
talk to you about Law and Order and
about dialogue between Republicans and
Democrats maybe we'll leave that aside
for a moment though and and concentrate
more on the
Republican side of the race uh for the
moment so as far as I can tell the Front
Runners are TR Trump obviously and then
DeSantis ramaswami Haley you and Tim
Scott you guys look like you're all
possible genuine contenders maybe
somebody else will pop up as we move
forward um the polls I looked at
indicate that Trump's running at about
48 to 50% desan is 12 to 16 ramaswami he
varies a lot say between 6 and 12 you
Pence and Scott somewhere between three
and seven and Nikki Haley at about 2 to
four now there are a lot of VAR there's
a lot of variability in the polls and I
don't know how accurate those figures
are but you can kind of identify
maybe who who are who's going to be part
of the actual slate now you you were
quite close with Trump you you helped
organize his campaigns you headed his
you headed the contingent that
established his presidency to begin with
my understanding is that you became
particularly skeptical of trump as a
consequence of his failure to fully
accept the results of the of the 2020
election so let's delve into the Trump
issue a little bit I think that's the
right place to go next and then talk
about the other Republican contenders
then I'd like to shift our attention if
we can to the Biden scandal and the
Biden presidency in general it'd be a
shame not to hit that so maybe we could
take about seven minutes to address the
Trump issue I I want to ask this
question you know Trump has been pushing
this notion that the election was stolen
and when I talk to my Democrat
informants they tell me that the
evidence for that from a legal
perspective is nil and it's very
difficult for me to evaluate that but
then I look at it from a broader
perspective and I think this is where
Trump is a genius and he's put his
finger on something which is that there
were a lot of terrible
Shenanigans um on the Democrat side of
the universe during the last election
and I think the worst of those was the
squelching of the hunter Biden laptops
story that was really to call that
appalling is to barely say anything at
all because that laptop's quite the damn
mess and God only knows what the bidens
have been up to and and that story was
squelched very conveniently in
relationship to timing of the election
which was a very tight election so Trump
might be wrong that the election was
stolen in a legal sense but that doesn't
mean he's wrong about it being stolen in
a moral sense and so well so that's
complic ated and and you worked very
closely with Trump and so I'd be more
than happy to hear whatever you have to
say on in relationship to those
questions well look um I was saying at
the time that the hunter Biden uh laptop
should have been a story but you know
what Jordan there are un unfair things
perpetuated by the media against
Republican candidates all the
time and we do have a media bias in our
country there is a liberal media bias
there's no question about that and the
problem though is when you're a
republican you got to be tough enough to
deal with it and not be a whining
child and my problem with Donald Trump
is now all of a sudden the problem is
well because they suppressed the hunter
Biden laptop I lost how about the fact
that you that you monumentally
botched certain elements of our response
to coid how about the fact that your
conduct while you were in office
absolutely Poison the Well with millions
of suburban women in this country who
had voted for him in 2016 and found him
to be an absolutely unacceptable
alternative in 2020 I mean you know much
of what we're talking about here was
self-inflicted and having been as close
to him as I've been over all these years
I could tell you that there were many of
us who were telling him that while he
was in the midst of doing it but he
doesn't listen Jordan he doesn't take
advice well he is incredibly
self-consumed and stubborn and you know
much of what happened to him in 2020
could have been avoided if he had listen
to lots of good advice which was
available to him and was being given to
him and he refused to accept it um and
he has morphed this into if his argument
was the campaign was unfair
that's an argument that I think a lot of
us could buy
into but he doesn't say that I mean if
you look at a recent interview he had on
Fox news with Brett Bear and Brett asked
him about those Suburban women that he
lost in 2020 and if he were the nominee
how would he get him back in 2024 his
response was I didn't lose in
2020 so I don't know what you're talking
about so so what do you think he did to
lose those women his conduct Jordan
his
abrasiveness his um his failures on the
coid front and his failures to keep his
promises look this is a guy who said he
was going to repeal and replace
Obamacare he had a republican Congress
he didn't get it done this is a guy who
said he was going to balance the budget
in four years as Preposterous as that
promise was he still did much worse he
added $6 trillion to the national debt
in four years the worst fiscal record in
four years any president in American
history he said he was going to build a
wall across the entire border of Mexico
and the United States and that Mexico
was going to pay for it and instead he
built 52 miles of new wall in four years
and we haven't gotten our first peso for
Mexico he said he was going to drain the
swamp Jordan and instead all he did was
rearrange the swamp and make room for
his own
family Jared Kushner and his daughter
aaka 6 months after he leaves the White
House gets $2 billion from the Saudis
after he made Jared a central part of
negotiations in the Middle East when he
had two very capable uh secretaries of
State in Rex Tillerson and Mike Pompeo
why was he doing that it's all a part of
the grift the Griff that allows him to
spend $40 million of his own money that
he raised from middleclass donors who
thought they were donating to him to
help him get reelected president on
legal fees as a billionaire he's not
spending his own money he's spending
$100 donor's money so I think all of
those things became
apparent during his time and a lot of
suburban women just said sorry we gave
you the benefit of the doubt in 2016
because we didn't like Hillary Clinton
and we thought you might actually drain
the swamp and do the things you said but
you didn't do them and in the process of
not doing them you also offended Us in
the way you conducted yourself as
president on a personal level and so
they left and I don't think any of that
will change Jordan in 2024 if he's the
nominee because all he's doing is
talking about the past you don't hear
him talking about the future all he's
doing is still he's still litigating the
2020 race he does that in 2024 which is
what he's been doing so far Joe Biden
will get reelected and that will be a
Calamity for this country to have a an
incapable 82-year-old
president going to 86 with a completely
incompetent Vice president okay so so
let's turn I'd like to dwell on Trump a
bit more especially in relation to the
Abraham Accords but I I think instead
we'll turn our attention to Biden and
so thec ramaswami tweeted out a few days
ago something I thought was extremely
ominous which was his
suspicions
that the question of whether or not
we're Tangled Up in the Ukraine war as a
consequence of the Biden family's
Financial dealings has now been laid on
the table and as far as I can tell
there's been a pretty stunning series of
Revelations emerging out of the W out of
the investigation into the Biden family
that they have taken substantial amounts
of money in a multitude of under the
protection of a multitude of different
corporate entities from foreign actors
in Ukraine and elsewhere something
approximating $20 million is the story
at the moment
and this is it's so shocking to me to
see this unfold that it's simpler for me
to believe that this is mostly mud
throwing and mck ring on the Republican
side now I don't believe that it is but
I can certainly understand how it would
be um reassuring for people to believe
that this is all smoke and no fire now
if Biden himself has being Tangled Up in
the Biden family business bus dealings
which seems to me highly probable given
that I can't understand what other value
Hunter Biden himself would bring to the
table then we have a scandal of a
proportion in the White House that
should make what's happening to Trump
look like a sideshow and yet that isn't
happening and so how are you reading
these Revelations about the Biden family
financial dealings with foreign
particularly with foreign actors and
what do you think it entails both both
of these families need to go
Jordan both the Trump family and the
Biden family who have placed themselves
and their own personal and pecuniary
interests ahead of the interest of the
country you know look $2 billion to
Jared
Kushner for what exactly his
extraordinary investment
Acumen you know you can ask the same
questions about Hunter Biden what value
is he bringing to the table except for
his relationship to his father now I do
think the V stuff about that's why we're
involved in Ukraine is laughable um we
were involved in Ukraine well before Joe
Biden never got to the White House
Donald Trump was sending weapons to the
ukrainians I don't think anybody thinks
that that was based upon some pecuniary
interest Donald Trump had and our
European allies are involved in this as
well so I I think this is V just being
him um and throwing that out there the
same way he threw out that you know he
doesn't think we know everything about
9/11 um and and the government hasn't
told us everything and then he had a
backtrack significantly off of that post
that he put up with one of the longest
posts I've ever seen trying to explain
away an irresponsible comment let's get
to the real Point here both the Trump
family and the Biden family have put
their own pecuniary interests of their
own families ahead of the interest of
this
country and for B Hunter Biden have
access to to getting his father while he
was vice president of the United States
on the phone with these business folks
that's what he was
selling it wasn't the illusion of access
as some of the Democrats say it was
access he got them on the phone to talk
to these clients and as a result these
clients paid him significant amounts of
money now whether the the president now
President Biden got some of that money
or not I think we should continue to
investigate and find out but my point to
you is that when you've got Don Trump
Donald Trump Jr's fiance getting paid
$60,000 in campaign money to give a
three-minute speech on January 6th when
you have campaign money donated by
regular Americans paying
$108,000 for Melania Trump's stylist
when you've got them paying
$250,000 to to refurbish his
plane there is examples of grift in both
of these families that are breathtaking
and every bit of it should be
investigated that's why I was calling
for a special counsel quite some time
ago to investigate the entire Biden
issue I'm very disappointed that they
appointed the guy who was obviously
either completely incompetent or in the
tank on the hunter Biden plea so badly
that a judge rejected The Plea but we
should be investigating the Biden
situation just as aggressively as we're
investigating the Trump situation and I
I'm tired of than
whataboutism it doesn't make Trump's
stuff not troubling his stuff is just as
troubling as Biden stuff they both need
to be looked at and my view is that both
of these families are past their cell by
date for leadership in this country and
we need to move on from both Trump and
Biden and by the way 75% of the American
people agree with that they don't want a
trump Biden race in November 24 so the
Biden stuff is serious and and it needs
to be examined in every way including
whether the president while he was vice
president or during the period he was a
private citizen was profiting from what
Hunter Biden was up to I know that when
you were
Governor i' I've been thinking here
while you're talking about you know why
you might be credible on the
uh anti-am Dynasty side of things let's
say and you know I don't know any
details about your own family and about
whether or not you might be someone less
amenable to that kind of pressure but I
do know that you ran what appeared to be
a pretty effective anti-corruption
campaign when you were attorney in New
Jersey and so maybe you could maybe you
could tell people a little bit about
that and then if you have anything to
say in closing to sum everything up that
we've been talking about and to you know
what put in a final word to the people
who are watching and listening we're
going to switch over to the Daily wire
side uh for another half an hour for
everyone watching and listening just so
you know talk about some of of of uh of
Mr Christie's
autobiographical history get to know him
a little bit better but we're going to
close this one up relatively quickly so
what did you do on the anti-corruption
front in New Jersey what did that teach
you about conducting such investigations
and what do you and then what do you
have to say in
conclusion well thanks for bringing that
up I look I'm the only person who's
going to be standing on that stage who's
had any experience dealing with Law and
Order and dealing with the issue in
particular political corruption it was a
huge problem in New Jersey when I became
us attorney there in 2002 and I
dedicated a significant amount of
resources to it and what were the
results we brought
130 in 7 years 130
prosecutions for political corruption
against both Republicans and
Democrats uh and the results Jordan we
were 130 and0 we did not lose one case
not one case was
dismissed and the reason for that goes
to my overall philosophy on this you
approach these problems without fear
favor or
partisanship you can't fear how big the
person is that's being examined you
can't favor someone um because they
powerful or Rich and you cannot ever
allow partisanship get into the middle
of it corruption is corruption no matter
who is performing it I remember the
first case I did involved the front
runner for United States Senate on the
Republican side in New Jersey in
2002 and a republican official called a
friend of mine when I brought the case
and said what the hell is he's doing I
thought he was one of us and my old law
partner said to him you don't understand
Chris
he's not one of us he's going to do what
he thinks is right and and I think what
it taught me was that the only way to
make Law and Order order efforts in this
regard seemed fair and just is for them
to be fair and just and completely
without fear favor or partisanship so if
I became president Jordan um I'm going
to appoint an attorney general with two
instructions one pursue every matter
that's appropriate to pursue without
fear fa favor of partisanship and two
don't come and ask me anything about any
criminal investigation that you're doing
the president has no business being
involved in it and when I was governor
by the way even though I had lots of
opinions about what my Attorneys General
were doing or not doing they'll all tell
you publicly that I never once picked up
the phone nor did anyone on my behalf
call and ask them anything or urge them
to do or not do anything um in a
criminal investigation that's the only
way the public can have faith in it in
the end I think what we need as a
president is someone who actually knows
how to get things done who actually has
a record of being able to work with both
sides and accomplish things who is
unafraid to use the bully pulpit in a
way that is appropriate to move opinion
both of the people that you represent
and of their representatives to try to
get things done and someone who believes
that it's harder to hate up close and
that what we all need to do is to work
together to try to get things
accomplished in this country our country
was set up Jordan constitutionally as
you know to be an
argument that's fine as long as the
argument leads to a result right now
we're living in a world of small
arguments about things that are just
meant to inflame and divide my
presidency is going to be about big
things of consequence to make our
country better 50 years from now not
five minutes from now in the next news
cycle well sir that seems like a good
place to close I'm going to flip to the
dailywire plus side of the interview now
for everyone watching and listening so
you can join us on the dailywire plus
platform if you would um thank you very
much for agreeing to talk to me today if
you're inclined you know a few months
down the road four months 5 months 6
months down the road when you're more in
the midst of the presidential campaign
and there'll be all sorts of new things
to discuss I'd be more more than happy
to talk to you again we can see how this
goes and and how people respond to it
but that offer is open I'm very curious
this is going to be a remarkably
dramatic and interesting presidential
election I think we haven't seen the
likes of this in our lifetimes you and I
were about the same age and so it's
going to be something to see it unfold
thank you very much for talking to me
today and for sharing your thoughts with
my viewers and my my listeners and uh
thanks to all of you who are in fact
watching and listening your attention is
much appreciated thanks to the Daily
wire folks for making this possible as
they always do and for making it work
out so professionally and easily and uh
on to the Daily wire plus side very nice
to talk to you sir thank you looking
forward to it
[Music]
Jordan